[Musique]
c'était une petite usine dans le
sud-ouest de la France en difficulté
financière mais l'invasion de l'Ukraine
par la Russie en février 2022 relance
l'activité du site aujourd'hui le seul
en France capable de produire des obus
de 155 mm stratégiques sur le front
ukrainien la situation en Ukraine a
rendu évident la nécessité de
souveraineté et donc de renforcer la
filière industrielle qui permet de
fabriquer les munitions les obus de5 mm
les forges de tar propriété d'uroplasma
ont pour projet de tripler leur
production passant de 55000 obus cette
année à 160000 d'ici 2026 une croissance
forte qui nécessite un doublement du
personnel c'est une des difficultés que
nous avons c'est le recrutement de
personnes qualifié on n'arrive pas à
trouver de personne et la plupart des
postes chez nous les formations son
entre 6 mois et un an ça veut dire qu'on
est énormément obligé d'anticiper des
difficultés qui ralentissent la montée
en puissance des industriels de la
défense malgré une politique
volontariste de l'État français en juin
2022 à l'occasion du salon d'armement
eurosatori Emmanuel Macron le chef de
l'État n'a pas hésité à parler
d'économie de
guerre jeen prie nous entrons dans une
économie de guerre ce qui est un
changement pour beaucoup d'entre nous
soyons lucide qui va nous obliger à
investir davantage pour les États à être
plus exigeant avec les industriels pour
ces derniers à être encore plus innovant
plus rapide le conflit ukrainien a
exposé les faiblesses occidentales en
matière de production de munitions après
la chute du mur de Berlin la France a
réduit de manière significative son
outil
industriel
désormais l'objectif est de remonter le
niveau des stocks et encourager les
industriels à produire plus et plus vite
on est plus proche de l'artisanat que de
la production de masse on vit dans un
temps où on l'impression que tout peut
être immédiat on peut se faire livrer
très rapidement les choses le monde du
digital est un monde de rapidité mais on
se rend compte que dans les mondes
concrets finalement bien construire une
machine ça prend du temps toute activité
industrielle se prépare quand on
augmente les cadences automobile dans
civile ou ailleurs et bien c'est une
planification sur plusieurs années dans
son usine de bourge Nexter knds fabrique
les canons qui équiperont son propre
système d'artillerie le César
l'entreprise qui n'en produisait que
deux par mois avant la guerre livre
désormais six véhicules tous les 30
jours en 2024 ce sera 8 une montée en
puissance rendu possible par des
investissements prévus bien avant le
conflit
ukrainien la machine é investie il y a
maintenant 3 ans elle est en
fonctionnement depuis 1 an c'était avant
le contexte actuel ukrainien cette
machine sera dupliqué on va en avoir une
deuxième qui va arriver courant 2024 et
cette machine a été anticipée en terme
d'avenir puisqu'aujourd'hui le 155 est
un tube de 9 m de long 52 calibrees
c'est un petit peu technique maintenant
les artilleries du futur cette machine
sera capacitaire de prendre un tube de
12 m de long 62 calibres la course est
donc lancée pour les industries comme
Nexter ns objectif répondre à la fois à
la forte demande ukrainienne et au
besoins des forces françaises car la
France a cédé 18 de ces canons César à
l'Ukraine et 12 autres sont en chemin si
l'entreprise peut aujourd'ui répondre à
cette demande croissante c'est parce que
la France au lendemain de la guerre
froide a fait le choix de maintenir les
compétences
industrielles en France on a toujours
cette notion d'autonomie stratégique on
cherche à avoir en fait fait l'ensemble
de la gamme donc on a fait le choix en
France de garder la plupart des
capacités parce qu'on voulait être
capable de les développer par nous-même
les produire en France avec des
partenaires parfois et donc on a fait le
choix de réduire Mina toutes les
productions plutôt que de sacrifier des
productions aujourd'hui en France
l'appareil de production semble prêt à
répondre au mot d'ordre de l'économie de
guerre dès 2018 les investissement avait
d'ailleurs augmenté avec une loi de
programmation militaire prévoyant des
budgets en forte ha
l'une des vitrines de ces
investissements est le Cerval un
véhicule blindé léger destiné à
remplacer les VAB véhicule de l'avant
blindé en fin de vie la conduite ça rien
à voir avec les Aes véhicules c'est
assez souple à conduire c'est facile
c'est très confortable et ça passe
vraiment partout franchissement se fait
assez simplement c'est facile bah nous
en tant que personnel à bord on sent
plus de confort plus en sécurité avec du
meilleur matériel qui est plus flide et
qui marche mieux et en plus de ce
confort apporté voilà il y a cette
nouvelle technologie qui marche bien qui
est fluide et c'est un vrai plaisir de
de contrôler tout
ça le marché du serval est accordé aux
industriels en 2018 dès 2023 plus de 100
véhicules sont déjà livrés et 100 de
plus équiperont l'armée française
courant 2024 une rapidité peu commune
pour un programme d'armement il y a
évidemment des défauts de jeunesse mais
sont des défauts sur lesquels la stat
travaille avec la DGA avec l'industriel
et les défauts sont identifiés ils sont
évidemment accessibles pour des
résolutions dans le dans des délis
courts et la base de l'engin est
extrêmement saine extrêmement positive
pour un engin qui qui arrive tout juste
dans les forces la nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire
2024-2030 confirme l'augmentation des
moyens mais cette hausse budgétaire ne
s'accompagne pas de commande de blindé
supplémentaire afin de maintenir les
cadences et avec la bénédiction de
l'État
les industriels se tournent vers
l'export la Belgique a signé un accord
avec la France pour l'achat de 19 Césars
et de 24 griffons dont la livraison est
prévue à l'horizon